well if one man knows all about
sacrifice mental resilience and winning
it's probably the fastest man in the
history of the world and in my opinion
the greatest athlete of all time usain
bolt won eight olympic gold medals he
holds a world record in the hundred and
two hundred meter sprints his blistering
9.58 second finish in 2009 remains
unassailed and his biggest achievement
of all i'm sure he would agree in his
most punishing assignment was that he
won soccer aid as captain in 2019 with
me as his manager and i inspired him to
score were you saying bolt returns to
london stadium this sunday to lead the
world 11 at soccerod again for unicef
and i'm delighted to say you're saying
joins me now well skipper i i still see
you as my skipper how are you
i'm good i'm good pierce i'm good
now obviously you you don't have your
world-class coach with you this time so
how confident are you that you can win
without me
i was planning to give you a call get
some tips just to make sure keep the
energy eye you know i mean ask you what
to tell the guys so
i just need that energy and i'm sure
we'll do well do you know what struck me
you say when i when i had the pleasure
of spending a few days with you on
soccer
i don't think i've ever seen anyone who
tried harder than you
to be brilliant at another sport
obviously you're the greatest athlete
that's ever lived but your dedication to
football is extraordinary you really do
love the game don't you
yeah definitely it's a it's a sports
that i really loved um coming up um as a
youngster and i watch as you know i'm a
manchester united supporter so
i definitely keep abreast of what's
going on in the world when it comes to
football so when i play i do want to
play at my best
a good friend of mine is cristiano
ronaldo obviously at manchester united
again at the moment and you're very
similar characters in the sense i think
at the core of your incredible success
the pair of you is a a an almost
unbelievable mental strength and
resilience that goes with your talent
i mean do you think that without that
you would have achieved anything like
the success you've had
no i definitely think you have to be
resilient and and never give up you know
i mean you have to always want to do
more um you have to never be satisfied
and i think that i agree with you i'm
like christian is like that he never
gives up no matter how much goals he
scores he wants to score more i was
watching him the other day and he scored
two goal and he missed one and he was so
upset with himself you know i mean
he just always wants to do more and do
better and and that's the kind of
mindset that gets you to the top
and keeps you there yeah i completely
agree and i think itself it's a
self-fulfilling thing it's got to come
from within hasn't it because no one can
teach that to people i don't think
right i fully agree with this you can't
teach that you have to learn that from a
young age and
and just through growing up and wanting
something you know i mean you can't you
can't teach us because we have tried to
explain to young guys coming up which
you see at the talent and they don't
really understand you know i mean so for
me i think you have to have that mindset
and that
drive to to want to be the best and just
want to be dominant
could you ever celebrate coming second
do you say anything
no i feel like no definitely not no
that's all you have to do is i'm a sore
loser i knew the answer
but the great champions are all sore
losers aren't they
you don't want to lose definitely
definitely
no no i want to talk to you no matter
what we're doing
yeah sorry yeah exactly yeah i want to
talk to you just about a few things that
are bubbling around the news which i was
really curious what your perspective
would be on it
the first one is the england football
manager gareth southgate came out a
couple of days ago and he was talking
about the
euros final last year where a young
black player bakay osaka actually plays
for my team arsenal missed a penalty and
so did several other black players they
got abused
racially abused because of it by
complete morons and southgate actually
said the other day that you know it
would make him think again in future
about whether he would let young black
players take penalties in that kind of
situation which i thought was an
incredibly dispiriting thing for him to
have to admit to what do you make what
do you make of that
that's that's tough to hear you know i
mean i've never i didn't hear this
comment but that's tough you know i mean
um
a lot of these guys they don't
understand the pressure
you know i mean standing in front of um
so many people in the weight of england
on your shoulder taking a penalty is no
joke and for somebody to say they
wouldn't give that person a chance
again to to prove themselves because
especially osaka is very young
he's new to it you know i mean it's hard
on the younger ones it's it's a learning
process you know i mean and he will get
better over the years so that's
that's tough to hear somebody said about
a black player i had
i think he did it from a kind of
protective viewpoint if you didn't want
to expose them to abuse but i don't
think you can take that view can you
no i think you have to give everybody a
chance you know i mean you have to give
that person a chance to
to be
himself you know i mean you learn from
your mistakes
and i'm sure you will learn from the
pressure and the more he plays football
the better you get so
i feel like everybody deserves a chance
you know i mean you should always give
the person the best player the chance to
go and prove himself and what advice do
you say would you give to a young black
athlete sportsman whatever who's getting
racially abused on social media whatever
it may be
you must have had this i guess over the
years because twitter and so on is full
of complete idiots but yeah what would
your advice be to how to handle that
for me i stayed away from all
social media all media outlets i never
read the news pretty much so my
when i started out young
i i went through that a lot and i
figured out if if i don't read the
comments if i don't read the newspaper
if i don't watch the news
then i won't hear you know i mean my
friends who are close around me um
they understand that they don't tell me
negative things
you know i mean so i just stayed away
from it you know i mean if you don't
read it if you don't listen to it you
won't hear so that's that's the same i
think that's very good advice the less
you read the better right and the purer
your head can be without this stuff in
your head yeah i want to turn to the um
this whole issue of sport washing you've
got it with the golf
stars at the moment who've decided to
play in a saudi arabian funded new
tournament and it's causing a huge
furore but at the center of it really is
this question of whether sports stars
should
uh have to be careful
about countries they align themselves
with for sport i know that you've i
don't think you've ever run
competitively in saudi but you've
certainly done some work there speeches
and so on
i mean what's your view about this
where's is there a line that you
wouldn't cross
for me i think everybody is different
views are different in these in these
times now everything is different it's
hard to to say what's going to offend
people you know i mean and it's
it's really tricky right now i have a
team that
kind of tried to protect me or try to
make sure we're on a straight line and
to make sure we don't
offend anybody as much as we possibly
can but it's it's tricky right now with
what's going on in the world with
everything you know you have to be very
careful with what you say and what you
do nowadays so it's just all about
understanding a situation
i mean i look at it and think there's a
lot of hypocrisy uh amongst the
criticism because if you have the
olympics in somewhere like china
and then i don't see an issue
particularly with golfers playing in a
saudi-sponsored golf tournament because
to me you either take a completely black
and white view of human rights records
of countries or you don't
yeah as i said it's it's all about
people look at things you know i mean
everybody has a different view
on everything this is why i stay away
from these things you know i mean i
again i have my team
i care for what i i say i just
try to stay focused on me and try to do
what i need to do to to stay
positive
what do you think of this issue you're
saying about trans athletes which is
obviously getting a lot of attention
at the moment a lot of people feel it's
unfair for trans athletes to compete
against women born to female biological
bodies you know we could have a
situation where if you wanted to
and you felt this way you could identify
as a woman and compete against women
would do you think that would be fair
reasonable
for me
i always say i'm not the person who
makes the rules you know i mean um even
when i was running and it was
the that i was asking about
drugs and who should be banned i always
say those are the rules
i think a lot of rules would be changed
in the future and it will be adjusted so
for me i just go along with the rules as
they are now
but do you think when you see what's
going on in swimming for example michael
phelps came out and said he didn't think
it was
fair would it be fair for for
sprinters who who've been born males to
then transition and compete against
women
well that's not for me to answer you
know i mean i think as again it's a
tricky situation
you know i mean it's
it's for discussion and it's not for me
to say you know i mean it's it's up in
here i would say but in time as i said
in times things will change
um so just give it time and see where it
goes
but just to clarify you're not thinking
of identifying as a woman any time soon
no
you've got you've got three you've got
three kids you're saying um they've got
fantastic names olympian lightning bolt
thunderbolt and st leo bolt so they've
all they've all i would imagine got the
bolt sprinting gene who's the quickest
uh well right now olympia my daughter is
definitely showing um
that she wants to run she runs
everywhere she's always on her toes she
walks on her toes like a sprinter so
that's something that i look forward to
but my boys are just one so i'm keeping
an eye on them
do you forget i've spoken to racing
drivers jensen button told me every time
he goes out in a car on a on a normal
road there's always some bloke in a pool
she wants to try it on with him at a
traffic light and zoom off
to you is the fastest man to ever live
do you find that everywhere you go
there's always somebody who wants to
try and take you down and what do you do
about it all the time it's all the time
um
for the older people i just laugh but if
kids if they really want to try i'll
i'll i'll race with them sometimes if i
have time on my hands
and sometimes i'll let them win if
there's a smaller kid but if bigger kids
i won't let them win
they've got to learn the hard way you're
saying that's how you learn how to win
um
jamaica's going through
younger kids
sorry god
for younger kids it's it's it's it's
it's much more fun to let them win you
know i mean because they're really fans
and they look up to you but all the kids
understand that
it's not always going to be easy to win
you know i mean so i have to let them
know you have to earn this you have to
earn you have to earn the win because
you know you say all the kids will brag
well i never let any of my kids beat me
at anything uh the problem is that three
of them now have got old enough where
they beat me at everything that's the
problem
well i think that's the winning match i
gave them gotta enjoy it yeah you gotta
enjoy it while it lasts you know i mean
i definitely think i'll be that dad also
yeah exactly yeah we've just had the the
platinum jubilee for the queen are you
saying um i just curious what you think
about jamaica jamaica looks like it
probably is going to head towards
independence how do you feel about that
for me
politics is not my thing
if you have you followed me throughout
the years i've always stayed away from
politics
um because
politics is is all over the place you
know
they're against one day and then they're
with one day so for me i had to stay
away from it totally i have no comments
on that whatsoever have you ever thought
of being a diplomat you say
yeah just sometimes
[Laughter]
i've been i've been trying i've been
trying here
um look best of luck best of luck in
soccer right
it was a fantastic experience it raises
a ton of money robbie williams who set
this thing up it's an amazing event
raises 10 11 12 million
and we had a glorious win together and
i'd like to think that my pre-match team
talk where i i read churchill quotes to
you all i think that may have been the
inspiration can you can you confirm that
i'm just saying yes this is why i said
i'll make a call i'll we'll talk off
here you tell me exactly what to say and
i can say to the guys in the in the
locker room you know i mean but i just
want to say to everybody no i mean go on
unicef website you know i mean
donate you know i mean um it's it's for
a good cause
it's for vaccination uh to fight my
nourishment
and it's it's wonderful you know i mean
so just come out and support and just
give all donations are doubled so it
would be great well if you need any last
minute tips on how to win you saying you
know where to come
definitely
best of luck and great to talk to you
all right all right thank you very much